i'm going to be calm i'm going to be
calm
no no no
oh my god what's happening hey guys it's
katie and i'm back with a very special
guest hi i'm annie kate from buzzfeed
india last time anakin taught me one of
his favorite recipes speaking only in
hindi and it was super fun so today
we're trying a new challenge we are
going to see if i can teach katie to
make one of my favorite burgers from
mcdonald's which is the aloo tikki
burger faster than mcdonald's can
deliver it to me in india i have never
had this burger it sounds delicious this
is gonna be crazy but i am so here for
it i cannot wait to see you struggle
katie
i'm not good at time challenges oh my
god four minutes oh my god i have a
minute 47 30 seconds
how quickly does it usually take
mcdonald's to deliver since the
mcdonald's is pretty close to my house
20 minutes no 20 minutes is the death of
me hopefully this recipe isn't too
complicated um
according to me it's not
but i don't know i think it might be
pretty easy to make considering you have
experience now from last time and you'll
be speaking english yeah i can speak in
english now finally i'm ready okay i've
got my alutiki uh burger and pdp fries
and a coke on my cart so i am making a
burger and fries i just took what a
clarify
yeah you are making burger and fries
just another thing to add aloo i
remember means potato i don't know what
tiki means though tiki means a patty oh
a parry okay i got a text it says
ordered let's start no okay okay you're
on a timer now katie let's go let's go
you can take the fries and and put it in
the oven chuck it there we'll deal with
them later i have a
sheep here just fries
just fries
does that look good
yeah oh yeah that's great that's great
that's enough wait how hot how hot in
the oven 450 how long 15 minutes okay
15. let's do 15. oh my god are you okay
timer set i don't know i'm freaking out
okay wait what do we need to do now do
you have a potato yes i have a potato
what do i need to do with the potatoes
chop it up just chop it up put it in a
bowl add some water and chuck it in the
microwave this is a terrible cut job
what am i doing don't look i can't see
but sure it's great i'm doing great
don't worry about it okay i'm just gonna
i'm gonna do it into smaller chunks so
hopefully it'll go fast in the microwave
i don't know if you if potatoes will
be boiled completely in five minutes but
we we can hope kitty it's in the kitchen
it's in the kitchen
it tells you that in the app check it in
the microwave quick okay okay okay okay
um just i have to
how quick do you think they are in the
kitchen at mcdonald's
very quick have you been to a mcdonald's
katie yes
okay five minutes five minutes okay
that's done yeah what should we do now
you can add oil to a pan and let it heat
so that we can use it to fry stuff later
and meanwhile let's make the batter for
the tikki kind of burger is this it's a
it's a potato burger potato patty burger
so we need to fry the patty once it's
out i'm doing a shallow fry because i
don't think we'll have time to wait for
this to like get up to a deep fry we
need to do like 53 things at once katie
okay i'm not i'm not a good multitasker
the oil is heating up the oil is heating
up what do i do now let's make the
batter for for the patty on the side in
a bowl take
all-purpose flour corn flour and salt so
that's flour
corn
starch which wait you guys call corn
starch corn flour
yes doesn't everybody call it corn flour
we call it corn starch or there's corn
meal oh we just we call cornstarch corn
flour because it's like a flour right oh
that's it is it does look like more like
flour yours is more accurate okay wait
okay so do i add salt salt
no salt yes salt
and add water for like a slightly thick
consistency i've just used two different
forks which just needs more dishes for
me to do later
is it too wet
i think that's fine that's fine we're
okay with fine also make the iconic
mcdonald's sauce now put some ketchup in
it and some mayo some red chili sauce
and mix it all up oh you're frozen
you're frozen oh you're back but i can't
hear you oh my god his wi-fi has gone
out no
well i've made this sauce
i've got oil eating and i've got
potatoes in the microwave and fries in
the oven and it has left me here alone
guys guys
what do i do
you're back
that was a scary moment for me
let's keep going
how does this look
but that looks exactly like mcdonald's
you said they've had this since you were
a kid i was six or seven years old i
went to mcdonald's for the first time as
a kid and i've had this since and it's
not changed it's the exact same and
reminds me of my childhood
oh okay i can't wait to try it but we
don't have time to be sentimental we
need to move and we don't have time for
emotions that's like me being a
sagittarian
wait the the potatoes just finished okay
now take them out mash them up really
good in the bowl oh my god what's
happening they're too hard they need to
go back in
i'm giving them three okay so what else
could we do should we make the seasoning
for the fries i got the stuff for the
seasoning in a bowl take some cayenne
pepper some sweet paprika do you have
everything right okay i think i just put
in cayenne i think that was cayenne
okay that was cayenne oh that's a lot of
cayenne yeah it is quite a lot of
cayenne is this tamarind yeah that is
tamarind powder put it in there i don't
think i've had tamarind that much what
is tamarind it's very flavorful and it
gives like a tangy taste to
all food so then i've got i think sugar
yes sugar
some dried oregano yep i have dried
oregano yep
garlic powder yes
onion powder yes salt okay um did you
add black pepper oh i do i have black
pepper right here it's getting hot in my
kitchen because it's 400 degrees
just mix it all up oh this looks pretty
okay does that look right
oh yeah that looks perfect oh wait the
microwave is done okay okay
seasoning he's done do any updates on
where it is
still in the kitchen that's strange it
being in the kitchen is a good thing
oh hey
they're kind of soft
that's fine maybe they can cook more
when we shallow fry them yeah they'll
cook more when we shallow fry them and
they're ma they're getting mashed
they're mashing
i'm noticing a theme potatoes
you love potatoes yeah we all love
potatoes they are just so versatile like
they can go anywhere and add
add character to the dish with your
potato burger do you always order fries
i do because i love the piri piri fries
that's like twice potato oh my god who
cares katie i don't i don't i think it's
great i think it's great i didn't even
think about it being double potato until
you brought it up
but i like it i like anything that's
double potato okay update it's on the
way okay okay okay does this look good
is this so good does this look good that
looks great that looks great let's let's
get let's get our patty started now okay
what do i do what do i do to your um
potatoes just add some peas green peas
um and all of the masalas which ones are
those the turmeric powder red chilli
powder coriander powder and cumin powder
cumin adjusted cumin and now last thing
i've got going in is the garlic paste
yeah add some ginger garlic paste and
some black pepper as well do you do salt
two yeah add some salt add some salt to
taste i'm done i'm mixing it together
and mixing it together
we need to make patties out of this
mixture now okay it's very hot so it's
going to be hard to handle no pain no
gain no pain no good
the fries are ready hold on oh my god
the fries need five more minutes
five more minutes i don't know if we
have that kind of time oh my god i can
see the guy on the little map
oh no no no no
i just spilled oil i'm making a patty
how big is this patty does this look
right is that good okay that looks
like a patty okay should i put him in
the oil yes oh no i shouldn't put him in
the oil he's gotta go on the batter oh
no no yeah it's going in the batter
sorry bread crumbs then batter then
breadcrumbs again and then oil i would
never do this with my hands i would not
but i am because this is where we're at
in oil in the oil yes yes in the pan
okay the oil is sort of hot enough i'm
gonna turn the heat up oh god okay let's
let's get the fries out
price fries fries okay the fries are out
what do i do with the fries what do i do
with the fries do you have a paper bag i
was wondering what this was for okay add
like a tablespoon of the of the spice
mix which we made i'm just gonna eyeball
it more periphery the better okay now
add the fries in there do we know where
he is is he closed
i don't think the location on the map is
updating so i don't know where he is but
he's definitely out for delivery it's
like a horror movie you don't know where
they are okay now just shake it
vigorously this is how they serve it
that's exactly how this little bit this
is fun
look at that
exactly that's what i'm talking about
okay i won't eat it yet i want to eat it
so badly okay what's happening with your
patty
i don't know the patty could be on fire
for all i know i don't know
okay oh it's very brown okay i gotta
flip it should i get the fixings oh yeah
let's do that but i still don't know
where the delivery guy is
i think we could beat him
i think we might how many minutes has it
been do you know it's been exactly 21
minutes right now flown by
it feels like it's been two minutes i'm
using brioche buns which seems kind of
fancy for mcdonald's
but they look pretty take the sauce and
put it on one side of the bun top bottom
doesn't matter bottom okay i'm going
bottom oh this looks good
now place some lettuce leaves do you
iceberg lettuce butter lettuce i have
iceberg all lettuce is good lettuce oh
all lettuce is good lettuce anakin i
think that this patty is probably done
okay let's put the patty on i feel like
i should put him on a paper towel first
or i'll just hold him in the air and let
him drip drip drip okay now add like two
onion rings two slices of tomato on it
okay great okay okay i've got the two
slices of tomato like top it off with
some sauce again
i used all of that sauce so
more sauce is great okay now close the
bun we are done
wait wait we're done
yes yes you won the challenge
we won the challenge oh we won the
challenge true and the delivery guy is
still not here
wow i'm like pretty proud i just want to
show you how tall
[Music]
maybe i should try to make another patty
let's try patty 2.0 try patty 2.0 this
is i'm feeling like we are over
achieving kids who would do an extra
project for extra credit for no reason
we could stop we could stop there but we
want to be the best and that's not
annoying at all
do you have you ever made this at home
it takes 20 minutes to reach my house
why would i make it all right i'm gonna
put this oh delivery is here i'm gonna
go get it
delivery is here
well we beat delivery
we didn't get the extra credit we didn't
get the extra credit though but you know
what that's fine this guy is pretty much
kind of done though
that seems more like a normal sized
fatty oh that's a that's that's good is
it too little now it is not too thin it
still looks quite huge i'm sure it's
it's it tastes great i'm going to clean
up and then let's compare
what i made with what mcdonald's
delivers
let's do that
let's taste test this is mine
that looks so good katie and it looks
like a gourmet burger let me show you
the actual
aloo tikki burger i mean you can see
the the sauce i don't think they put
lettuce in this
wait i have lettuce i have lettuce on
this burger
that that just makes it go to me okay
should we try it
let's try it
unbelievable i am shocked by how tasty
that is the sauce is sweet and spicy and
tangy and then that patty just has so
many spices and flavors like you get the
curry there's the peas in there but they
need to have this in the united states
i'm so glad you liked it because i love
this burger so much there is so much
going on it's like the quickest easiest
burger to get from mcdonald's also i
think this burger is like the most
popular burger at mcdonald's india
that's why they've never taken it off
the menu i feel like i'm gonna start a
campaign to get this on our menu let's
check the fries fries were probably my
favorite cooking part of this because
they're so fun to make they're so fun to
assemble so first the fries
this is like an activity kit like i this
is so fun
in goes
the masala why is it called piri piri or
is it piri piri not sure why it's called
pvp if you know in the comments let us
know let me shake them
if you wanted to get a party going
just order the period
my fries are ready
nice should we do this
this is like one of my favorite meals i
don't think i can go back to normal
fries after this you know what and also
i feel like i wouldn't overeat it
because it's like it's just packed with
so much flavor i would feel very
satisfied but you can probably just get
fries from mcdonald's and add your
homemade seasoning to it wait can i get
chris to come try this burger yeah chris
this burger looks really good
that is delicious is that so good i
thought it was very very tasty can i try
one of these fries these are puri perry
fries yeah these are way better than um
than our fries yeah once you go piri
piri you can't go back to normal that's
absolutely true i've never eaten another
fry again this is about as this is as
good as it can well that solves some
problem thank you
annika thank you so much for teaching me
how to make one of the most amazing
burgers i've ever eaten in my life also
you guys be sure to check out buzzfeed
india they are making some amazing
content subscribe to buzzfeed india and
let us know in the comments below what i
should teach katie next i'm scared but
it'll be fun let's find out until next
time bye bye bye bye
oh yes
[Music]
you